HAD BEEN HACKED BY RUSSIA.
MUELLER WANTS TO KNOW WHAT ROGER
STONE KNEW AND WHEN HE KNEW IT.
BRET?
>> Bret: JOHN, THANK YOU.
YOU INFORMATION TONIGHT ABOUT
THE INFAMOUS TRUMP TOWER MEETING
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENTS SON,
DONALD TRUMP JR., AND SOME OF
HIS FATHER'S CAMPAIGN ADS AS
WELL AS A RUSSIAN LAWYER WHO
SUPPOSEDLY HAD DAMAGING
INFORMATION ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON, OR IT WAS
THOUGHT SO AT THE TIME.
PETER DOOCY IS ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH THE LATEST.
>> DONALD TRUMP JR. IS THAT HE
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUN
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUN0
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUN6
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNW
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNE
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNN
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNR
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNS
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNI
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNN
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNS
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNC
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNM
KEPT HIS DAD IN THE DARK IN JUNE
CULLING WITH POTENTIAL DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY ASKED, WHY WASN'T I TOLD
ABOUT THIS MEETING?
NO HE DIDN'T.
DID YOU FIND THAT AUDIT?
NO, BECAUSE HE WASN'T AWARE OF
IT.
THE MEETING ALMOST DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
ROB GOLDSTONE TOLD CONGRESS, I
BELIEVED IT WAS A BAD IDEA AND
WE SHOULDN'T DO IT AND I GAVE
THE REASON FOR THAT BEING, I'M A
MUSIC PUBLICIST.
POLITICS I KNEW NOTHING ABOUT.
ONCE THE MEETING STARTED, THINGS
UNFOLDED LIKE THIS, ACCORDING TO
A U.N. CITIZEN OF GEORGIAN
DESCENT WHO WORKS FOR A GROUP
RUN BY A RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS.
MR. TRUMP ASKED IF THEY GOT
ANYTHING ON HILLARY, TO WHICH HE
RESPONDED, WHY DON'T YOU DO YOUR
OWN RESEARCH ON HER, WE GAVE YOU
THE IDEA.
BUT THE RUSSIAN LOBBYIST WAS
ASKED BY INVESTIGATORS, WAS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OF ANYTHING
THAT MIGHT REASONABLY CONSIDER
COLLUSION BETWEEN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ON THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT?
NOT THE WAY I UNDERSTAND IT,
NOAH.
TRUMP JR. TOLD CONGRESS THAT,
THE MEETING WAS INSTEAD
PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON RUSSIAN
ADOPTIONS.
TODAY, TRUMP JR. SAID THE PUBLIC
CAN NOW SEE THAT OH FOUR OVER
FIVE HOURS I ANSWERED EVERY
QUESTION ASKED AND WAS CANDID
AND FORTHRIGHT WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS, NOT SO
SURE OF.
>> I HAVE NO CONFIDENCE THAT HE
HAS TOLD THE WHOLE TRUTH.
>> Reporter: AND SO THE TOP
REPUBLICAN ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MADE DURING TRUMP JR.
BACK TO TESTIFY AGAIN.
>> I WILL TAKE IT UNDER
ADVISEMENT.
>> THIS MORNING OBAMA MORNING
OBAMA OFFICIALS BRIEFED A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF SENATORS HOW
THEY CAME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
RUSSIANS MEDDLED TO HELP TRUMP
IN
IN AND I SEE A WHICH REPORTEDLY
RELIED ON THE UNVERIFIED DIRTY
DOSSIER.
AND IN A BREAK WITH HOUSE
REPUBLICANS, REPUBLICAN CHAIRMAN
RICHARD BURRIS SAYS QUOTE WE SEE
NO REASON TO DISPUTE THE
CONCLUSIONS.
"TODAY'S TALKS FOCUS LESS ON
TRUMP CAMPAIGN COLLUSION AND
MORE ON RUSSIANS USING FACEBOOK
AND TWITTER TO INTERFERE.
>> WE NEVER HAD SOCIAL MEDIA TO
THIS EXTENT IN ANY OTHER
ELECTION BEFORE.
>> FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN AND SECURITY ADVISOR
JAMES CLAPPER WERE NOT CHATTING
LEAVING THEIR CLOSED-DOOR
MEETING.
>> WHAT CAN YOU TELL IS ABOUT
TODAY?
>> Reporter: SO THE LAST
GENERATION OF SPY CHIEFS WAS
CHARACTERISTICALLY TIGHT-LIPPED
AS THE NEXT GENERATION GOT
ANOTHER STEP CLOSER TO THE
DIRECTOR'S OFFICE AT LANGLEY.
GINA HASPELL WAS EASILY
CONFIRMED TODAY BY THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
NEXT STOP, A FULL SENATE